mi vuoi sposare hehehe
h ah ah ah
[Musica]
che non è uno scherzo no
c'è una torta con la panna magari
[Musica]
posso toglierla
È una sorpresa ah ah
[Musica]
ah ah ah
Ah tu
ah ah
[Musica]
tu Ah bello Tu vuoi evitare vero
e zia No non ce l'avrai mai Vitale
perché Vitale Al momento l'ho già detto
non avrei mai Vitale Vitale è solo mio
è così
No
io non me ne vado Mi dispiace io non me
ne andrò e quindi siccome non me ne
andrò mai Vitale solo mio AH AH AH
AH AH AH AH AH AH AH
AH
AH AH
ho capito la lupa vuole mangiarmi perché
se mi mangerà io non ci sarò più vitale
sarà costretto a sposarlo no
no mi dicare
quanto vuoi
anche
Se mi vuoi male
Anzi Vitale
[Musica]
invece di fantasticare in tutto questo
tempo Dov'è finito Vitale non lo vedo da
un sacco tu sai dov'è
No non sai dov'è se tu non sai dov'è e
neanche io so dov'è Dov'è Vitale
sì Io rimango qua Tanto sono in prigione
no
[Musica]
heheheh ah ah ok faccio finta
bellissimo Sono riuscita a far
allontanare la lupa così proverò a
evadere da questa prigione adesso
ma mi sono nascosto benissimo la lupa
ancora non mi ha trovato qui Ma che fine
ha fatto Anita te sarà finita
[Musica]
E tu che ci fai qua
stai cercando Vitale
Guarda l'ho visto da quella parte sì e
poi dopo scappavo di corsa di là di là
guarda là
Oh no Devo trovare il modo di riuscire a
uscire da
questa freccia e aspetta prima la lupa
ha sbattuto qua e ha fatto cadere due
sbarre della prigione non li ha
posizionate bene
Ce l'ho fatta
Sì sono uscita dalla prigione Ora non mi
resta che cercare l'Italia presto
andiamo
ancora tu che cosa c'è questa volta
io tu Croce X per Ok scusa Oh stai zitto
ok
io e te con
[Musica]
facciamo il karaoke
bello è divertente Cantiamo Insieme
Esatto aspetta Ma dov'è finita Anita non
è che l'hai fatto qualcosa
[Musica]
che cosa sono queste moguglini
più o meno come più o meno che cosa
intendi con più o meno
no Se io se io vedere
Anita e io voglio vedere Anita se io
voglio vedere Anita Sì
io e te
saluto
[Musica]
dobbiamo ballare E baciarci
pezzo di aver capito che cosa intendo
però non lo voglio fare Quindi se
riproviamo se io e te voglio se io se io
voglio vedere Alida io e te ci dobbiamo
non è abbracciare
Allora se io voglio rivedere Anita io e
te ci dobbiamo sposare nonno
non voglio ma è l'unico modo per vedere
a Rita però
E quindi che cosa dobbiamo fare Dobbiamo
sposarci
ce l'hai me l'hai detto prima l'anello
Come no
mi devo inginocchiare a fare la proposta
a te ah ah
ah
sto piangendo prima ancora di fare la
proposta
[Musica]
devo dire Devo dire che cosa va bene
Luca mi vuoi sposare Hahaha
sì ha detto Sì che bello come sono
felice
[Musica]
matrimonio della Lupa e anche accettato
aspetta Ho un piano
[Musica]
Ma adesso che ti ho fatto la proposta ti
ho dato l'anello e tutto quanto Adesso
mi fai vedere Anita per favore
no Come no Ma come no mi hai detto che
il vostro matrimonio se voglio vedere la
vita zitto
se voglio rivedere Anita Sì
[Musica]
ho capito Dobbiamo celebrare il
matrimonio adesso
hai organizzato tutto Non lo sapevo
guarda
[Musica]
ma quindi adesso che cosa dobbiamo fare
Dobbiamo aspettare quello che ci sposa
ma io in realtà mi aspettavo il mio
matrimonio con Anita no con te eh Guarda
che cosa mi tocca fare pur di rivedere
Anita
[Musica]
sono venuto qua per celebrare il
matrimonio di Vitale e Lupa giusto
perfetto iniziamo subito
Benissimo siamo qui riuniti e celebrare
il matrimonio del signor Vitale con la
signora
[Musica]
Allora iniziamo subito vuoi tu prendere
signor Vitale come tu a legittima sposa
la signora Lupa
mi sa che non ho molta molta scelta
sì per rivedere Anita sì
voi tu Lupa prendere come tuo legittimo
sposo il signor Vitale finché morte non
vi separi
Ma sei sicura
benissimo potete ora scambiarvi gli
anelli
[Musica]
[Risate]
può baciare la sposa ma siamo sicuri
Bisogna proprio farlo
[Musica]
possiamo farlo dopo il bacio magari no
Per ufficializzare devi baciare la sposa
ok
e ora Per ufficializzare questo
matrimonio non deve esserci nessuna
opposizione
c'è qualcuno che si oppone a questo
matrimonio
Io mi oppongo io
[Musica]
io
sono Luisa non mi riconosci Sì questo
matrimonio è annullato Mi dispiace per
te Luca Oh grazie Scusa no
aspetta aspetta aspetta
avevo già pensato a un piano ci sta per
arrivare il testimone di nozze
No ragazzi allora cosa sta succedendo
Qui no
sì Ti ricordi che ti eri innamorata
anche di lui perché è un bellissimo lupo
Eccolo qua Eccolo eccolo
invitato il vostro matrimonio perché c'è
quel lupo che schifo perché c'è quello
lì Ma perché è vestito da sposa che
schifo niente Tu sei pensavi di essere
testimone ma in realtà sei il nuovo
sposo il nuovo sposo della lupa Ma che
io co chi Con lei sì mi avete incastrato
un'altra volta un'altra trappola Wow
Ah ah ah ah ah
quindi ri corrila pure